[Music]
I love you what is it like constantly
getting reactions from people saying you
were such a huge part of my childhood
it's wonderful it reinforces what we try
to do we feel like we did it didn't have
an idea that we'd be talking about it a
year after we made it
legendary Canadian Children's Group
Sharon Lois and Bram prepare for their
final performance at the Elgin and
Winter Garden Theater in Toronto on
November 5th with both Sharon and Bram
however Never Say Never As The Duo tease
that they could continue touring is it
true brand that this will be your final
public performance with Sharon Lewis
well
I keep saying so Sharon says well we'll
see
I Say Never Say Never
[Music]
we're like family we're very we're like
family that gets along we are we are
great friends we've been involved in
each other's lives forever with well
since you were teenagers really and this
this career is 45 years but you were
folk singers in the same Community yeah
we met in the 60s every day we have a
new exciting piece of news about
something special that's going to happen
it really is going to be a beautiful
celebration it'll be a massive Sharon
Lois and Bram sing-along yep the
audience will sing their hearts out and
so on see y'all next time
my life
[Music]